Andy I do understand that you had a
little adventure the other day that you
want to share with us here at the show I
went on a little field trip there's a
bus that goes out to the Hamptons which
for those of you at home who don't know
what that is that's an area that is sort
of it's known as a wealthy resort area
out on Long Island where a lot of you
know rich people here in New York have
their vacation that's right and there's
a bus that travels out there for two
peoples weekend homes that is a beauty
bus they call it it's like a salon on
wheels so in the time that they can that
they drive out there they can get their
hair done and manicure and pedicure and
it's a very vital service for people
yeah that's very sad that it's even
necessary yeah yeah well let's take a
look at Andy's trip on the Hamptons
beauty bus enjoy
among the milk and a la Beauty groups
Beauty Express or as most New Yorkers
know it the beauty bus which is a bus
that takes people up to their vacation
homes in the Hamptons since out in the
at the beach in Long Island it takes
them from the Upper East Side and while
they make the trip out to their vacation
homes they get to have a beauty makeover
so they get there and they're ready for
their weekend I kind of always felt like
my hands look like mmm like plump
Cornish hens that's okay
models are nail-biters
well I would say that 50%
have you ever sent of the bite their
nails of course for 50% of them biting
their nails is probably considered lunch
look at that
my nails have never been more shiny I
feel like a gangster now do you ever
think about a beauty blimp a beauty you
know an airship like a beauty Zeppelin
nothing I think about the beauty jet
beauty jet not a beauty balloon no
Beauty goecart no Beauty moped Beauty
train yeah yacht yeah not bad but I
think Beauty train would be good too cuz
it sounds like a disco song the Beauty
Train okay
[Music]
bite their toenails
[Music]
passion
[Music]
passion
[Music]
they got my shoes and see this
[Music]
[Applause]
we'll take a quick break when we come
back Arianna Huffington will be with us
stick around